but the funny thing is if the men were
not working on their careers we would
not want them anyway and what you can
see is this is a control tactic of
modern women women are not meant to
control men women are not meant to
control their husbands their husbands
are supposed to follow their purpose and
the women are supposed to follow but we
have Brainwashed the media into
convincing women that we need our
emotional needs met that we need
um that he has to spend a certain amount
of time at home with us that we get to
dictate what is acceptable for him to be
a family man and then we'll keep our
last names which is not traditional yeah
well divorces asked and then when he
moves on we'll cry about it and my
question is why is it that she was able
to move on and Tom Brady said nothing
about it but yet when he moves on she's
got an issue